okay I'm back it's it's good to be back
as you know I I now have one more kid
than I had the last time we spoke we've
experienced child inflation which I
guess makes it sound like our kids are
getting fed what I mean is that is that
we we had a baby so another one that's
that's the fourth one and I want to
thank everyone first of all has sent
nice emails and messages over the last
few days and there were a lot of people
sending things well wishes and prayers
and congratulations everything and it
does mean a lot to me and I really
appreciate it
my wife appreciates it too so I thank
you for that to those who have been
asking yeah the the delivery went went
very well at least from my perspective
it went well I you know I was more in a
spectator role so I didn't I didn't have
quite as much to do so you know as far
as I'm concerned because it was actually
pretty easy to be honnest but and the
baby's healthy my wife is healthy at the
end of it that's the main thing I will
say you know we went in on Wednesday for
an induction because the doctor said
they needed to induce for a few medical
and health reasons they're gonna induce
the the birth and but that process took
about 12 hours there's a 12-hour thing
it was actually so long that I left
halfway through I was sent by my wife I
should say she sent me to go buy a
boardgame I went to a bookstore actually
I left the hospital so this was
technically during labor I left the
hospital during labor to go buy a board
game that we could play while this whole
process was happening and and I got
Stratego by the way great game I'll tell
you there was there was there was just
one little sort of hick hiccup I guess
one dicey moment that I'll tell you
about and that happened actually on the
way to the hospital because we were
driving there and my wife was talking
about the difficulties of labor you know
how hard it is and everything and so I
was trying to be sympathetic and I'm
listen but I'm trying to listen and be
sympathetic but also but also respond
right I'm it's it's it's a two-way comm
so I observed very helpfully I think
that the reason why labor is hard for
women is that human females are unique
among the large mammals in that they
have very small relatively small birth
canals and the babies heads are
relatively large and that's sort of a
unique thing when you say that's the
point I was trying to make it's just
really just a sort of a biological
observation but the only thing that my
wife latched on to is she paused for a
minute and she said wait so you're
you're telling me I'm a large mammal is
that what you're saying
and I said no well I mean well yes I'm
saying that but that's not it's I mean
not you're not the largest and not like
a hippo or something I I didn't mean but
not like that I'm saying that it's just
it's it's I'm saying technically humans
are large mammals okay that's all I'm
trying to say anyway she took me out of
context it was a total fake news moment
and so we went everything else turned
out okay and and the baby's here now and
we're just enjoying you know the
opportunity to not sleep because the
baby's on a fun schedule where she's she
sleeps the entire day and she wakes up
at about 11:15 and then stays awake the
entire night and so that's been that's
been a lot of that's been a lot of fun
and that's the thing about infants is
that I've had four of them now and I can
say from experience infants are really
easy to deal with from about a 7 a.m. to
11 p.m.
they're extremely easy in that timeframe
because they just lie around they don't
do anything they just lie there they
aren't going to literally climb the
walls like my six-year-old son and
they're not going to scream because they
can't find their paw patrol pajama pants
like my three-year-olds on and they're
not gonna talk back like my six-year-old
daughter then I got do any of that they
just they just lie there thinking about
whatever babies think about but then at
night that's when they sort of clock in
so at nighttime there's a transition
where my my older kids clock out and
they kind of passed the baton
to the infant and they say okay we've
been annoying mom and dad all day now
it's your turn and then that's when the
infant comes to life and she says all
right I'm ready to do this let's do it
and so then we don't sleep all night
which is why and this is the last thing
I'll say this is what its really leading
to when when people come to me and they
ask for parenting advice which for some
god-awful reason happens a lot this is
what I always say here's my advice and
it's a really it's a really important
tip you're not gonna hear this a lot of
places be rich that's my advice just be
rich as rich as possible I mean a
multi-millionaire at the least because
if you're rich then you can hire a night
nurse to take care of the kid at night
and then you can sleep and then even
during the day you can hire a nanny and
so you don't really have anything to do
that's what makes parenting the easiest
you know you might not expect that but
if you can hire someone to do everything
then you don't have to do anything so
just be rich that's my advice I admit
that I have not taken my own advice in
that regard but if you can do it I would
say definitely be rich choosing between
the two options not rich or rich just be
rich that's my that's my slogan in life
all right let's um let's let's get into
the the news I want to talk first about
corporate cowardice because there's a
lot of it these days but this thing with
the NBA and China is just it's such a
perfect encapsulation of corporate
cowardice in so many ways now let's back
up for a moment if haven't been paying
attention to the story over the weekend
the general manager of the Houston
Rockets Daryl Morey tweeted out well he
tweeted out support for the the
pro-democracy protesters in Hong Kong it
was just a little graphic and the
graphic said fight for freedom stand
with Hong Kong that's it that's all he
said pretty simple message and most
people in this country agree with it
because we're all fans of freedom at
least in theory in practice many of us
are not quite so much but in theory we
all think that freedom is a great thing
well China is of course a communist
country and they're run by a regime that
is not a fan of freedom in theory or
practice they're just really not into
the whole freedom thing and the other
thing about China is that they love the
NBA and they especially love the Houston
Rockets because Yao Ming a great Houston
rocket his Chinese he retired a while
ago of course but his time on the
Rockets made that team one of the
favorites in China so they still love
they still love the NBA and they love
the Rockets as it happens Ming is now
the president of the Chinese Basketball
Association and he came out with the
Chinese government to express their hurt
feelings over this little tweet that
just said support what it was a fight
for freedom China got their feelings
hurt because you know the f-word just is
not you can't say that in China they
didn't like it at all and neither did
the NBA because they make a lot of money
from China so the NBA immediately issued
a statement hoping to patch things up by
prostrating themselves in front of this
the communist regime of China and
licking their boots and here's what what
at what what the NBA said just a a
remarkable display of cowardice the NBA
said we recognize that the views
expressed by Houston Rockets general
manager Daryl Morey have deeply offended
many of our friends and fans in China
which is regrettable while Daryl has
made it clear that his tweet does not
represent the Rockets or the NBA the
values of the league support individuals
educating themselves and sharing their
views on matters important to them we
have a great respect for the history and
culture of China and hope that sports in
the NBA can be used as a unifying force
to bridge cultural divides and bring
people together and then Maury himself
don't make the mistake of thinking that
he stuck to his guns and held the line
he didn't do that at all he dropped his
guns and he fled from the line at the
speed of light essentially and he issued
his own statement this is what he said
he said I did not intend
to cause any offense to rocket fans and
friends of mine in China I was merely
voicing one thought based on one
interpretation of one complicated event
I have had a lot of opportunities since
that tweet to hear and consider other
perspectives I've always appreciated the
significant support our Chinese fans and
sponsors have provided and I would hope
that those who are upset will know that
offending or misunderstanding them was
not my intention my tweets are my own
and in no way represent the Rockets or
the NBA remember what his initial what
the initial thing was he just said fight
for freedom that's all it was so now he
has apparently heard other perspectives
about freedom he's heard from the anti
freedom crowd and and I guess they made
some really good points about how
freedom actually isn't that good and so
now he's reconsidering and he's saying
listen I thought freedom was good I
thought I was in favor of it but I've
I've listened to you know totalitarian
Chinese Communists and they raised some
good points and so now I just so look I
you know they're they're two sizes thing
and he's not the only one who's
listening to both sides of the freedom
verse tyranny discussion Steve Kerr
coach of the Golden State Warriors and
someone who was usually very outspoken
about political issues and usually
cannot wait to jump in and insert
himself into all kinds of issues that
have nothing to do with basketball well
now you have a political issue that does
have something to do with basketball it
is directly associated with the NBA and
so you would think that Steve Kerr would
would be eager to he would just be
chomping at the bit to UM to champing at
the bit actually is that it's not
chomping at the bit as the incorrect
phrase there anyway he would just be
eager to get in there and say something
but that actually isn't how it worked
out here's what he he was asked if he
has a comment on the China situation and
here's what he said
actually I don't really really bizarre
international story a lot of us don't
know what to make of it's something I'm
reading about just like everybody is but
I'm not going to comment further
oh he's reading about it you see he's
reading about whether China's
suppression and persecution of
pro-democracy protesters is good or not
so he's doing some reading he's
considering the angles you see and he
doesn't want to comment it would be it'd
be irresponsible for him to come now
just for comparison's sake just for just
for fun and for comparison let's
reminisce about how Steve Kerr responded
after the election of Donald Trump now
with with something like that a u.s.
election first of all it has nothing
directly to do with the NBA second there
are certainly multiple sides a
complicated issue you could do a lot of
reading about it but on that her was was
very eager to share his opinions and
here's what he said about that for me
the probably the biggest disappointment
with this whole election was the level
of discourse you know there should be
some level of decorum and respect and
dignity that goes with the election of
the presidency and it was like went out
the window and maybe we should have seen
it coming over the last ten years you
know you look at society look at what's
popular you know people are getting paid
millions of dollars to go on TV and
scream at each other whether it's in
sports or politics or entertainment and
and I guess it was only a matter of time
before it spilled into politics but you
know then all of a sudden you're faced
with the reality that that the man who's
gonna lead you is as routinely used
racist and misogynist insulting words
that's that's a tough one that's a tough
one and I you know I I wish
and well I hope he's a good president I
have no idea what kind of president
he'll be because he hasn't said any
anything about what he's going to do we
don't know but it's it's tough when you
when you when you want there to be some
respect and dignity and and there hasn't
been any and this goes on for several
minutes by the way he goes on and on and
there have been many other rants from
Kerr about Trump he is again very
willing to pontificate about that but
not on China meanwhile other rockets
players like James Harden have joined in
the boot licking fest now Harden was let
me play this clip he I think they were
in Tokyo for exhibition game or
something and and this is what he had to
say about China you know we love try
that we love no playing there I know for
both of us individually we go there you
know once or twice a year they show us
the most important love so you know we
appreciate as a fan base and we love
everything you know there about and and
you know we appreciate the support that
they give us individually and as an
organization so you know we love of
course all of this groveling amounts to
nothing as usual because there are still
boycotts now in China and China's state
controlled media is dropping NBA games
so as I always say with these situations
that number one you should never
apologize for the truth in the first
place no matter the consequences if what
you said is true and right supporting
freedom is true and right you shouldn't
apologize but even on a more pragmatic
level it won't matter if you do it never
does because whether your apology to
communists or your apology to the
American left and that's basically a
distinction without a difference they're
not gonna forgive you anyway so there's
no point you might as well just say hey
yeah I said it I'd say it again you
might as well take that approach because
it won't matter you can grovel and
and and and kiss their feet and he will
make no difference and that's what's
happening here by the way I read about
that the backlash in China how they're
still boycotting and dropping games
anything I read about it in a yahoo
article actually think it's an AP
article that Yahoo is running but with
with a very bizarre headline here's the
headline of this article it says NBA
chief NBA chief silver stands firm as
China backlash amounts and here's the
lead the National Basketball Association
won't gag its personnel or apologize
over a team executives tweet that
ignited a firestorm in China
Commissioner Adam Silver insisted
Tuesday standing firm despite a growing
backlash that imperils the league's
lucrative Chinese following now wait as
I go the NBA did apologize I just read
it to you that was M it might not have
said the words we apologize but that was
definitely in apology and they are
clearly gagging their personnel there's
a reason why it's not a coincidence that
the NBA players are either saying
nothing refusing to comment or coming
out and apologizing so the AP or Yahoo
is is running running cover for the NBA
which itself is running cover for a
communist regime so duplicity and
cowardice just abound in this case I
called this a perfect perfect
encapsulation
of corporate cowardice precisely because
of this comparison between the NBA's
approach to trump and its approach to
China because if you're an NBA coach or
a player there is no downside to
attacking Donald Trump all your friends
are gonna agree with you many of the
fans will agree everyone on the team is
going to agree so it's the media will
certainly agree and they're gonna
celebrate whatever you say so you risk
nothing by criticizing him in fact you
may actually credit risk something by
not criticizing him to fail to join the
chorus criticizing Trump if you're in
the NBA you're free you're in a position
like that
that could actually be where the risk
comes in yet with China okay now there's
something on the line because China has
a lot of money and a lot of power and a
lot of influence obviously standing up
against them really standing up against
them not the fake stance that that that
you know Yahoo is pretending then the
NBA is taking but really standing up
would be risky and that's why all of
these outspoken these supposedly
outspoken players and coaches and
personnel they've all run for the hills
because they want nothing to do with
this I think with the word courage is
way overused in our society and there
are so many people who get credit for
saying courage supposedly courageous
things when if you if you look at what
they had to say whether what they said
was true or not there's no courage in it
because they didn't risk anything in
saying it it's only courageous taking a
stance is only courageous it can only be
courageous if you are really risking
something but if you are if what you're
gonna say it will be appealing to all of
the people who you need to appeal to
there's no courage there so this is just
utterly shameful disgraceful cowardice
and you know the all of the the kneeling
and everything that that happened in the
NFL and there was a little bit of it in
the NBA certainly NBA players supported
have been outspoken in their support for
the kneeling that happened at in the NFL
well again if
if these players really want to have
courage and if they really care about
standing up against oppression which is
supposedly what that whole anthem stunt
was about well you know now they're
they'll all link arms and and make some
kind of demonstration against China
because that is gonna take guts if they
really cared about it if all that anthem
stuff was was was anything more than
just a publicity stunt
then these players are going to come out
and and make a meaningful stance against
China but of course we know it all was a
policies done so they're going to remain
silent and and take their marching
orders and just go along with it alright
a couple other things this was this was
kind of funny I wanted to mention it
briefly a guy named David W Brown I've
no idea who he is but he has a blue
check mark on Twitter so he must be
important and he wrote an article
lamenting the fact that women are
failing apparently the army combat
fitness test and here's his sort of
summary on the link that he posted on
Twitter said leaked leaked reveal the
catastrophic failure of the army combat
fitness test
if 84 percent of women are failing your
physical fitness test 72 percent in a
single preposterous event you're not
trying to make a stronger army you're
trying to force women out so 84 percent
of women are failing this test and it
says in the article that 70 percent of
men are passing so that's 30 percent are
failing that's almost three times as
many women failing as men now what does
that tell you well it tells you that
women are built differently that women
are not as strong as men it further
tells you that most women are not
physically suited for combat that's
that's literally what it tells you right
it's the combat fitness test so if most
women are failing it it would seem to
mean that most women are not fit for
combat which which is not a big surprise
but how is this all manipulated and
twisted
David Brown says no if you see it's not
women failing the test it's the test
failing women that's what he says if
women fail it well then there must be
something wrong with the test is a now
if eighty-four percent of women were
passing the test then we would say oh
this is the best greatest test it's a
wonderful test this test proves that men
and women are equal in fact women are
better than men so if women if if the
tests were getting the results that the
left wants then we will be told that
this is the greatest and most accurate
physical fitness test of all time but
it's not and so no there's something
wrong with the test forget about it and
that you know I guess I can't really
quibble with the logic because that's
the exact same argument I tried to make
in high school all the time you know
where I would say yes teacher this this
test this math test seems to be broken
or something because I got I got I you
know I got every question wrong I got a
zero percent so there's something wrong
with it
oh what's that I'm I'm just stupid
you're say okay well maybe that's it
could be that or it could be either way
so this is just how desperate people are
to avoid basic biological realities
which is that men and women are
different men are stronger and that's it
and of course ironically what ends up
happening is in this effort to protect
women or to get women involved or
whatever they're trying to do you end up
undermining the women who are really
exceptional because yeah eighty-four
percent of women are failing this test
but that means that 16 percent I could
still do the math on this one I think
sixteen percent right 84 plus 16 that
means sixty percent of women are passing
it which means that those women are
really exceptional so if you change the
test and you make it easier then all
you've done is you have undermined the
achievement of these really exceptional
women let's see
other things oh here sorry I saw this
headline from CNN I just I don't really
have anything to say about I just wanted
to point it out the the the headline is
dog owners are 24% less likely to die
for any reason but the life prolonging
benefits are even higher for anyone with
cardiovascular disease according to two
new studies I just I couldn't I saw that
online today and I I couldn't pass it
over less dog owners are 24% less likely
to die for any reason so no I haven't
looked at the study and I hate to be the
guy who contradicts scientific findings
without actually researching them I
admit I haven't done my research on this
I do though have to doubt whether dog
ownership actually imbues in mortality
into the dog owner because that's what
that headline would seem - if you're
less likely to die for any reason then
so that would be your immortal I guess
and anyway if but here's the thing even
if that's true that as long as you own a
dog you'll be immortal again I have some
issues I suspect there's some problems
with them with the methodology of this
study but even if that's true I would
say that
wellmaybe mortality isn't so bad then
because I'd rather be dead than live
with a dog for all eternity so it's kind
of a catch-22 it's like yeah you can
live forever but you got to have this
hairy beast around you at all times for
all eternity in that case I would say
you know what death isn't so bad
actually
death is a little bit underrated you
might say all right um speaking of CNN
they have CNN has been completely
obsessed with this joker movie now as
you know leading up to the release of
the film The Joker movie came out over
the weekend leading up to the release of
it the media not just CNN but the media
in general the mass media they were
really rooting hard for a mass shooting
to happen at one of these screenings and
I know that may sound harsh to say that
they were rooting for a shooting but I
don't know how else to characterize it
because story after story headline after
headline I'm sure you saw them talking
about the worries and fears and and and
everything that someone might shoot up a
joker screening that it might inspire
violence and so on and why is that
where were they getting this from why
did they randomly decide that we should
be worried that someone's gonna that
this specific movie is gonna inspire
violence and there's gonna be a mass
shooting at a movie theater is it
because of the Colorado theater shooter
who dressed in Joker costs you no makeup
and said he was the Joker well no it
couldn't be that because the Colorado
theater shooter actually didn't dress
like the Joker and didn't claim to be
the Joker and didn't do or say anything
associated with the Joker at all that
was maybe you didn't know that
a lot of people still don't that whole
thing about the Joker shooter he said he
was a that was all that that didn't that
didn't have the shooting happened but
he'd never said he was the Joker that
was invented by the media that was a
media narrative that they invented I
guess because it makes the shooting more
spectacular so where did this idea come
from that someone might attack a Joker
screening well it was also invented by
the media there was no reason to worry
about it
but they kept suggesting it in the form
of cautions and warnings over and over
again saying oh gee I hope someone
doesn't shoot up the Joker's it would
really be a shame if someone shoots up
the Joker screening and then and then
you know so how else am I supposed to
interpret that it would really seem like
that's what the media wanted to happen
because they kept bringing it up
suggesting it and then the movie comes
out and a bunch of people go see it it
gets breaks all these records everything
no violence nobody shot up the any
theatres and so what does the media do
they immediately pivot to other Joker
related concerns let me give you an
example of let me give you an example of
some of the headlines from CNN
over the last few days about the Joker
the Joker movie I'll read a couple one
is a Joker the film about a marginalized
clown who goes on a killing rampage is
facing a wave of criticism that it
glorifies a killer and could encourage
copycat attacks another headline the
true appeal of the new Joker movie lies
in its invidious validation of the white
male resentment the help bring President
Trump to power of course you got it by
the way in the invidious validations
would be a great name for a indie band
but aside from that of course we gotta
bring Trump into this another headline
Joker is a cash grab by a major studio
which capitalizes on intellectual
property with 80 years of history Oh a
cash grab yeah because this of course
the Joker movie is the first superhero
movie to be a cash grab right now so
yeah and then this wasn't much this one
was my favorite
this was a headline yesterday last night
from CNN says rock and roll part to a
song by convicted child sex offender
Gary Glitter plays for about two minutes
as Joaquin Phoenix who plays the Joker
dances down a flight of stairs that in
particular all of those headlines are
ridiculous that last one you know rock
and roll part 2 nobody even knows you
hear that name the song you know you
don't know what that but you've heard
that song a million times if you ever if
you've ever been to any stadium any
sports stadium of any kind you have
heard that song it plays in every
stadium in America at every level it's
the you know it's the most people know
it as the hey song that song where it
plays a beat and then everyone shouts
hey right that's that's the song so
that's a song that nobody knows the name
of it we've all heard a million times
they played in stadiums across the
country and and apparently news to me he
the guy who wrote that song is a sex
offender and so now somehow CNN is
trying to makes a tie-in between that
and the Joker it's just this is you talk
about grasping at straws it's completely
desperate but CNN is not the only one of
course they've been there's been a lot
of talk of joker glorifying violence and
encouraging violence and on and on well
I did see the movie and
so I want to go order to get my brief
thoughts on it and kind of chime in on
this whole on the hype surrounding it
and everything so first of all as for
the hype and the concerns about
encouraging violence and all that well
as I suspected it was completely on word
or unwarranted yes it is a violent movie
it's not even close to the most violent
movie to come out even it's certainly
not the most violent movie to come out
this year probably not the most violent
movie that will come out this month it's
just there are tons of violent movies we
could we could all name right now off
the top of our heads 50 movies that are
more violent than this movie is and
here's just one for example John wick
okay
now like 800 characters die in every
John wick movie he just goes around
shooting everybody and yet the media
doesn't freak out about violence in John
wick movies nearly to the same degree
that they freaked out about Joker really
the media is okay with any and all
violence in movies and on TV unless it's
this particular Joker movie or a Mel
Gibson movie those are the two times so
they've kind of expanded their
repertoire a little bit because usually
they they'll say nothing about violence
in movies because they don't care and
they just wait for Mel Gibson to come
out with a movie and then all of a
sudden they care there's all this
violence and they I never forget of
course Passion of the Christ would be
the primary example of this Passion of
Christ comes out and the media they're
very concerned about the violence it's
so violent it's so brutal and it was
around the same time that Kill Bill I
think was either volume 1 or volume 2
came out I think it was in the same year
that one of those and the same media
personalities that were lamenting the
violence and Passion of the Christ
they loved Kill Bill it was critically
acclaimed meanwhile there's a scene in
that movie and either volume 1 or 2 that
the entire movie is ridiculously violent
there's a scene in volume 1 or 2
the protagonist Huma Thurmond she she
like she decapitate a hundred people and
one she fights off I mean it's a pretty
impressive fight see but she just is
dude with a sword she just decapitate
one person after another just heads
rolling all over the place no problem
with that that's fine but this movie is
the violence is too much so that's the
way it goes does this movie actually
glorify violence I would say no not at
all actually I agree that some movies do
glorify violence and that is a problem
a movie glorifying violence isn't going
to cause real-world violence it doesn't
work that way it's not a one-to-one
causal relationship where somebody goes
and they see violence in a movie and
they say oh I think I want to commit
violence also and then they go out and
do it it's not the way it works it's
much more complicated in that but people
are influenced by the images they see on
a screen and when you go when you watch
a movie or you sit down you watch TV you
are immersing yourself in this world the
fantasy world and you're in some sense
giving yourself over to it
subconsciously at least and you're
certainly susceptible to being
influenced and so I would agree that it
is a it's a it can be a problem when
people marinate their minds in all of
this stuff that does glorify violence
but just because there's violence in a
movie that does not mean that the movie
is glorifying it a movie that glorifies
violence is a movie that makes it seem
cool and fun and sexy you know that's
that's a movie that glorifies violence
but Joker does not do that at all the
violence in this movie is it's not fun
it's not funny it's brutal and it's
random and it's disturbing and it's sad
it's the the entire movie is very sad in
fact that's one thing that surprised me
about it I you know I I went I didn't go
into it expecting it to
barrel of laughs but I was actually
surprised by how sad the movie is from
the first scene to the last it's a very
sad movie and that's the way the
violence is portrayed that's how it
comes across you don't it's it's it
doesn't look there's nothing glorifying
about it you leave the movie feeling
like that was very sad to see all that
which is which is how you should react
to violence and so violence I think in a
movie or a show it's it's only a problem
when it elicits the wrong sort of
reaction as for the quality of the film
itself well like everybody says
Phoenix's performance walking Phoenix as
Joker was mesmerizing performance which
is nothing new because Joaquin Phoenix
has been one of the best and certainly
the most interesting actor in Hollywood
for a long time I thought it was very
engrossing it was captivating it's a
character study about a man on the
fringes of society slowly losing his
grip on reality a man who as he says in
the movie explaining to a social worker
that he over time started to question
whether he even exists he started to get
this feeling like he doesn't exist
and so the outbursts of violence towards
the end of the movie was really about
him asserting his existence on the world
and saying hey look at me I exist which
is which is is is true to life that is
that's I think what is that's why most
mass killers do what they do because
they're trying to assert their exist
they're trying to exist to be seen to be
noticed and which which to point that
out is not to excuse it by a longshot
it's just to give insight into what
drives these disturbed people it's not a
movie for everyone that's for sure
as I said there's brutal violence in the
movie it's a slow burn it builds tension
gradually it's not an action film it's
not a superhero film really and even
though it's selling tickets like a
superhero film it's not and that I think
that was my takeaway that I think is the
best thing
about the movie is that basically the
filmmakers tricked a mass audience to
rush to the theater and watch this movie
to watch essentially an arthouse
character study about a man's descent
into madness they tricked everyone to go
watch this movie by attaching a
superhero brand to it which they didn't
need to do it's not essential to the
plot or the story at all because the
superhero tie-ins the the the Batman
tie-ins there's a few of them but it's
it's it you could cut that out and it
would do nothing to impair the story
whatsoever it was completely unnecessary
except that it you know we are so
programmed to we want the brand name we
want the superheroes if those are the
only movies that anybody will pay to go
see anymore and so I guess the people
behind this movie they said all right
okay if that's the only way we can get
people to watch this movie then we'll
just we'll call a joker it's not even a
joker movie the character's name is
Arthur Fleck so they could cut out a
couple scenes with with you know Bruce
Wayne's father take those scenes out
call it Arthur Fleck instead of Joker
and the problem is that nobody would go
see it you put Joker on it people go see
it and that is is is maybe the greatest
trick that the Joker has pulled in a
sense you might say by tricking all
these people to go watch a movie that
this movie has no business being a
blockbuster and I don't see that it's a
that as a criticism I think it's a it's
a good interesting movie that makes you
think but it's just again you take Joker
off you call it Arthur or something and
it's the kind of movie that would be
released in select theaters for a week
and then it would be on demand so you
could watch on Comcast or Netflix or
something it's just it's that kind of
movie it's it's not the kind of movie
that would normally sell 100 million
whatever it was hundred million dollars
in the first weekend or whatever was and
I think that maybe there's more to the
branding choice than that even at one
level it exploits our our obsession with
brand names and superheroes
in exploitation that I appreciated
personally I thought it was pretty
pretty genius at another level though a
deeper level I think maybe the movie is
is yeah you could argue is saying
something about the kind of stylistic
violence that we all enjoy in things
like superhero movies without ever
considering what we're really watching
so this movie's Joker is is what a super
villain would be like in real life
nothing super really just a villain
insane violent brutal a sad pitiful sort
of character not funny not silly no
superpowers nothing like that just a
disturbed and violent man so maybe this
movie is saying to the audience oh you
want supervillains okay well well here
you go how's this and then some people
recoil and say well hey this is this is
problematic this is this is
inappropriate this is violent yet normal
superhero movies depict death and
destruction on a large scale all the
time they just do it they do it without
the blood and they do it with a few
one-liners and quips and everything and
so nobody notices you're still being
exposed to the violence it's just you
don't notice it because you've got
Robert Downey jr. and cracking a joke
and they don't really have the blood
it's just the you know the building
comes down and you imagine there's
probably a thousand people inside who
just died but you don't really see it
and so this movie I think makes you
notice what is actually happening and
what the implications really are I don't
think the movie is saying that we
shouldn't watch superhero movies I think
it just causes you to stop and think
about what you're watching and why
exactly some forms of violence in
entertainment disturb you while others
you find whimsical and fun so it just
makes you think in general and and I
think that's it's it's very unusual for
a blockbuster film to do that and so I
appreciate it for that reason and I
would say it's worth watching for that
reason I would hesitate
to say that I recommend it because I
don't think it's a movie for everyone
and I think there's a lot of people
watching this or listening to this who
judging by other emails I've gotten this
probably is not your taste so but if you
know going in that it is yes it's a sad
movie there's brutal moments there's
blood if you know that going in you're
prepared for that then I think that
there you know there are there are
things you can take from it and it does
you know I just think it's there's not
enough of that where you go you watch a
movie in the theater and on the way home
you have something to talk about you're
actually talking about the movie and the
issues it brings up and you know was it
it just yes there should be more of that
with movies I think and unlike most
superhero movies where you go you watch
it you leave and five seconds later you
forget what even happened you couldn't
even talk about it because you don't
even remember it was just it was just
colors and images and things happening
and and who knows so I appreciate it for
that reason
alright we will we'll leave it there no
emails today we'll get back to that
tomorrow Matt Walsh Oh at gmail commas
email address if you want to chime in
with your opinion on this movie or
anything else we talked about today
and I will talk to you tomorrow gods be
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on it into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there
[Music]